hey Scott but he just saw Hannah Brown
finds out one of her contestants has a
girlfriend so I knew you're nervous
coming in today it might be because you
have a girlfriend I don't have a
girlfriend on Monday night's season
premiere of The Bachelorette
Hannah's friends from her bachelor past
Demi and Katie hid out in a surveillance
van to help her see who really came on
the show for the right reasons okay this
is not the guy earlier today someone
reached out to me on social media saying
that one of the guys here has a
girlfriend that's him that's the guy
with the girlfriend I'm here to find the
one for me Scott claimed he broke up
with his girlfriend just days before
coming on the show I could also say that
you just dated Colton for the last like
two months three months like you were
just madly in love with him and then all
the sudden now that this is like the
same Hannah wasn't having it and hit him
with the facts you are such a jerk and
at all you have another girl at home but
you still have on the line and that I'm
I'm done with this there's no reason for
you to be here if you're not serious but
she was having all the fields for Luke
who received the coveted first
impression rose and a kiss I really
liked you and I wanted you to know that
Sam
Oh bleep will you accept this raised
without a doubt okay seriously though I
just want you to know like this
seriously means the world to me
and the affirmation that you do I mean
it's just been like I feel like I'm
living an athlete dreaming about cannas
season of The Bachelorette is off and
running we have a feeling we'll be
hearing plenty of that this season and
from what the season promote seized we
can expect a lot more drama a train
wreck promise and having physical
relationship
and I Jesus still loves me
how dare I be judged by me will you have
an engagement at the end of this that is
that is what I hope for yeah I think of
course like my my hope is to you I've
been to this have somebody that knows me
and knows all of me and I know them and
I feel very confident about them getting
down on a knee and asking for the rest
of their life with me and I can say yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]